the united states ruled out the most
ambitious vaccination program in
american history
to the applause of workers at pfizer's
michigan vaccine plant
it is a test of an unprecedented
national effort to save millions of
lives in the nation most ravaged by the
pandemic
workers load dry ice into boxes
containing the super chilled vaccine
kept at negative 70 degrees celsius
then in a scene not witnessed in this
century vaccine-bearing fedex and ups
delivery trucks are escorted by u.s
marshals the shipments are expected to
reach the first 145 locations on monday
and a total of 636 by wednesday
20 million vaccinations this this month
and then we think we'll be up to 50
million total vaccinations
of of people by the end of january and
100 million
shots in arms by the end of february
just with the modern advisor vaccine
but amid the celebration there are
warning signs
to achieve the hurt immunity necessary
to stop the disease in the u.s
virologists say 75 percent of the public
must be vaccinated
but in a study of one health care system
florida's jackson health system
half of the health care workers said
they would not be taking the vaccine
another 35 percent said they would not
take it in the first round
the head of the u.s national institutes
of health says that's a major concern
i would like to plead to people who are
listening to this this morning
to really hit the reset button on
whatever they think they knew about this
vaccine that might cause them to be so
skeptical
please people when you look back in a
year
and you say to yourself did i do the
right thing i hope you'll be able to say
yes
because i looked at the evidence across
the u.s
the virus is reaching new peaks the
state of mississippi reports
it now has no more intensive care beds
available
what i fear that people do not
understand
however is that the resources are
finite they are
finite there gets to a point when we
have to say
we don't have another place to put
another
patient safely we can't do it
with nearly 300 000 dead and new
infections rising
the human toll continues to mount john
hendren
al jazeera washington